historically it sort of always been
interesting because it sort of
potentially a bit earth-like and of
course there was all the story about
canals on Mars and potential for life
there and so on so it kind of captures
people's imaginations so Mars is the Red
Planet
it's the fourth one from the Sun so our
neighbor it's about half the size of the
earth
so it has weaker gravity than we do
astronomically is it's a bit of an
enigma because it's sort of rather like
the earth in a lot of ways it's a bit
further from the Sun and so it's a bit
cooler down and so on and yet it's very
very different when you actually come to
look at it in detail you can see some
other features even kind of make it out
when it's close but through small
binoculars or speaker small telescopes
you can see some of the polar caps that
look white and you can see Red Planet
and you can see it almost looks like
canals or things originally about 1900s
people really thought there were
man-made or you know intervening
synthetic now what's the word I'm
looking for synthetic means man-made
Martian made technologically we could
have gone to Mars probably any time in
the last 10 20 years really there's
nothing that's been stopping us apart
from the amount it would cost and so it
is somewhere we could go and we could
certainly establish a presence there
it's a fairly hostile environment in
some ways it's a little bit less hostile
than moon because at least it has a
little bit of an atmosphere and so on
but you know we can live it with very
hostile places and Mars is probably no
more hostile and some of the places on
earth like the deep oceans or on the
near the poles where we've established a
presence so yes we could go and live
there this is a very cool picture I'm
not actually sure whether it's the North
or the South Pole I think it's the South
Pole of Mars and what you can see is the
the mass surface and you can see there
are these dark and brighter areas and
then on the pole you can see white stuff
and this white stuff is very very likely
ice what eyes as we know it this is what
I'm us you idiot I love it t-minus 10 9
8 7 we've been studying Mars for a long
time with telescopes from the ground but
we've also sent a lot of telescopes and
instruments to Mars zero and liftoff of
the Delta 2 rocket with Phoenix
distant science outposts seeking clues
of the evolution at the polar region of
Mars
so the Mariner was the first one in the
60s and then since then we've sent maybe
a dozen some of them orbit around and
take very detailed images but some
actually land so we've set these little
robots down to land on the surface and
crawl around and pick up soil and see
what they see it's a slightly
unfortunate one because a lot of the
missions to Mars are failed and so
actually it kind of is astronomy a bit
of a bad reputation and it's slightly
strange um it's over half of the
missions to Mars to a greater or lesser
extent haven't worked
of course this has led to all sorts of
entertaining conspiracy theories about
how the little green men unplug them
when they arrive and all those kinds of
things actually there were good reasons
why missions to Mars are quite hard when
you compare it because the thing you
compare it to most often are missions to
the outer planets where you're just
doing a flyby quite often in the case of
Mars you're trying to land something on
the Martian surface and Mars is very
hard to land on the surface of because
it's got some atmosphere which just
makes it difficult to land but not
enough atmosphere to actually slow you
down that might show you have to do
quite clever things in order to actually
get things to land on Mars at all two of
my favorite little robots they sent our
opportunity and spirit Rovers robust
little guys they actually were scheduled
to land they landed on two different
parts of the planet they were scheduled
to perform experiments for 90 days so
three months but it turns out that they
were incredibly successful and they just
kept going and kept going and kept going
so that they landed in 2004 but they're
actually still going sort of the weather
on Mars although Mars doesn't have much
by way of an atmosphere it does have
some weather and so you do have these
big dust storms that blow up and
actually you get also much more
localised dust features so you end up
with these things like little tornados
these dust devil things which fly around
which are only discovered relatively
recently and it turns out they're
actually quite useful because we've had
these various little Rovers running
around the surface of Mars and it was
thought they'd have a lifetime of less
than a year because dust would just
build up on their solar panels which is
the things that's giving them their
power and so it was thought they would
just kind of run out of steam because
the dust would build up and there
wouldn't be enough sunlight getting
through so they'd stopped working but
conveniently these little dust devils
seem to fly around the place once in a
while if one passes over the top of one
of these they blow all the dust off
again so these little Rovers have had
three or four times a lifetime anyone
was expecting just because the dust was
getting blown off by these little mini
tornadoes the types of information that
these Rovers have brought back are just
astounding they've seen direct evidence
for liquid water flowing in the past we
don't see liquid water now the the
pressure in the atmosphere is too low
for water on the surface but we see ice
water ice and the polar caps and we can
see it evidence of it on the surface so
we can see valleys and we can see
riverbeds and we can see sediments
laying down a river called Phoenix
actually dug a little ditch and when I
took the first picture of the ditch they
saw these white bright patches in the
ditch and they thought at first maybe
this is salt maybe it's water ice maybe
it's condensed carbon dioxide but after
four days they took another image and
the bright spots completely disappeared
so it couldn't have been salt and it
couldn't have evaporated if it was
carbon dioxide so it was frozen water
that they uncovered that just evaporated
in into the atmosphere and so this is a
picture from the mass global survey M
and it's again one of the polar regions
and you can see this nice small ice
field in this crater
so the crater is on one of the poles and
because it's a crater and it's under
poles there's some regions where light
never gets to so yeah ice can form them
well as we know it's very easy to
identify faces and familiar structures
when we look at images and things that
we don't know so one of the first images
that was taken of Mars many people saw a
face you can see two eyes and a mouth
and subsequently pictures of
higher-resolution show that what that
actually was just shadows of different
hills so we our eyes wanted to identify
this as a face but in reality it was
just unresolved shadows from Hills most
of the planets around the solar system
have magnetic fields to a greater or
lesser extent and they're sort of
important so for example the earth one
the magnetic field channels all the
charged particles away from the surface
or at least towards the poles so they
don't all the all the high-energy
particles in space don't just come
piling straight down onto the surface in
a radiating that's all and so the
existence of a magnetic field is thought
to be part of partly responsible for the
life on earth that you've got to avoid
irradiating your surface too much in
order for life to develop so having a
fairly strong magnetic field is quite
important
Mars is a bit strange because it doesn't
actually have a particularly strong
magnetic field it's even though it's
more or less the twin of Earth in a lot
of ways it doesn't have that strong kind
of bipolar magnetic field so it doesn't
look like a bar magnet if you figure out
what its magnetic field looks like and
so it's a little different and it's
still a slightly unsolved problem in
astronomy as to why Mars firstly doesn't
have very much by our magnetic field but
actually if you look again more closely
you find it does at least have sort of
residual bits and pieces of magnetic
field then Mars has two moons they're
very close they orbit very closely to
the planet and they're oddly structured
they're blong they're not actually
spherical they're pretty pathetic moons
to be fair you know that so this is two
moons going around Mars Deimos and
Phobos and and they're only each about
sort of twenty kilometres across the
closest one Phobos is actually only 17
kilometres in diameter so about a
marathon race from one side to the other
and the other one is Deimos and it's a
little farther out and it's even smaller
so it has two moons but they're really
just kind of pebbles in the cosmic scale
of things but actually they're on quite
low orbit so the interesting thing is
although Phobos to say is only 20
kilometers across all they're about so
it's very small because it orbits so
close to the surface if you're actually
standing on the surface of Mars and
looked up at it all about appear about a
third the size of the full moon so it
actually appears a reasonable side
because even though it's a fairly small
pebble in the scale of things it's
actually all in such a low orbit that it
kind of appears quite large in this coin
olympus mons yes tallest mountain in the
solar system ola it's very dull because
actually it's kind of a you know it
isn't it is a mountain in it it's huge
much higher than Everest it's got a
diameter of roughly 600 kilometers the
height is 26 kilometers so it's a lot
lot bigger than any mountain on earth
but actually it sort of it's very gentle
slope so you could just sort of gently
walk up it it really wouldn't be a very
spectacular or inspiring climb to the
top and I've actually got one picture
which is a size comparison so in the
background you can see Olympus Mons and
then this left bit here that's the
Himalaya Himalaya
with Mount Everest there's also this
Grand Canyon type things as it would
deep the deep
Canyon in the solar system as well as
thought to be all Mars I think the
reason why you have these sort of
superlatives on Mars is because it's
kind of it has a relatively low gravity
which means you can have big features
and they don't just fall down but it's
also relatively stable and so it's this
combination of having a surface which is
pretty stable so features can just sort
of stay there but gravity is
sufficiently weak that actually even
these very big features can exist
without just getting getting falling
down under their own weight and I guess
also the absence of an atmosphere which
means things don't weather away as well
all credit to go in to the moon the moon
is an amazing place but it's actually
pretty dull it's sort of you know
featureless gray there's not a whole lot
to see whereas Mars you know you have
all these different types of rock these
you know you can actually you get these
beautiful panoramic views you can see a
bit of atmosphere there you can see the
sunlight filtering through it it really
looks like a place and I I must say I'm
inspired by I love for people to go
there